[Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  Ronnie Ronnie are you home okay there  you are you want to go play what's wrong  nothing's wrong what's on your face I  said it's nothing more sweets Ronnie  that's your second hunk of candy bar  this week you know good nutrition it's a  matter of state security if father found  out it will be straight to the youth  health ministry for you Mike it's  disgusting and it's dishonorable don't  you remember your lessons about honor to  be honorable you must have courage to be  honorable you must exercise self-control  all great things in the service of a  fatherland are honorable that's better  I'm still gonna have to inform on you  [Music]  [Music]